Hey Youtubers! This is Charlie.
So hopefully you have all had a chance to see episode 1 of Korra Book 4.
This is gonna be my review.
And just because this is the first episode and there is a lot of stuff to get through I made it a little bit longer.
And there is gonna be a top 10.
Heads up too. It looks like Amazon is gonna be releasing episodes at midnight pacific time.
That's Thursday night or Friday morning. However you look at it.
Nickelodeon posts them on their website a little before noon.
So, if you are willing to pay a couple of dollars extra, you can watch the episode
like 8-12 hours before everyone else.
And again I know you guys all be happy to know the weekly giveaway is back.
All you have to do is enter, is be a subscriber and leave a comment on this video.
I'll announce the winner whenever I post my Q&A tomorrow.
But... Careful for spoilers if you haven't seen the episode yet.
Okay. Here we go.
Top 10 moments: Number 10.
Three years later.
The high speed rail system,
Team Korra being pulled in all different directions,
the new Earth Kingdom prince,
And Kuvira's mission to fix the mess in the Earth Kingdom.
The world has changed a lot and the characters have changed a lot.
Number 9: Meet Wu prince of the Earth Kingdom.
I couldn't find any information on who the voice actor was
but I'll try to find out by the time I post my Q&A video Saturday.
Or if you do know just write it in the comments.
There is a whole lot to say about him.
But he gives all kind of exposition about what's been happening in the Earth Kingdom.
Kuvira has been cleaning up the mess
and he has been living in exile.
We also find out how he is related to Hou-Ting.
They are like distant relatives, distant cousins.
So he probably just came from one of really wealthy families in Ba Sing Se.
Based on the rest of the episode
it seems like he is going to be on one side of the conflict and Kuvira on the other.
With the prise being the throne of the Earth Kingdom.
The whole scene with the pies just let us know
that Kuvira has pretty much won over the populace.
Like she is gonna get the popular vote.
But president Reiko from Republic City is backing Wu.
So, I am wondering if the other nations of the world are gonna back him too.
It's probably just because he feels like Wu is much easier to deal with than a really powerful war lord.
I don't think that president Reiko is gonna be a villian or anything,
I just think he is a politician through and through.
If you remenber that trailer scene with Zuko, his daughter and president Reiko.
It seems like other nations are gonna back Wu.
And that's gonna cause the greater conflict. That's gonna be like the spark in the flame.
It's gonna set Book 4 off.
It'll be like the politicians of the world versus Kuvira and her army of the people.
Number 8: Team Korra montage.
So we start learning where everyone is and how they've changed.
Three years does not sound like a lot but
everyone is little bit more mature
and they have gone from teenagers arguing about relationships
to young adults arguing about politics.
I also saw that a bunch of you were confused about some scenes in the trailers
where looked like Team Korra people were fighting each other.
That's not the case and I'll totally explain it.
You can see though how that might end up happening
based on everyone getting pulled in different directions.
Team Korra is not gonna be broken apart for that long.
Like they'll get back together eventually.
Number 7: Kai and Opal to the rescue.
So this was just like Mako's intro scene during Book 2 all over again.
He gets that really cool motorcycle chase intro
when he does that
big, you know firebending take down of those criminals.
The Triple Threat Triads I think.
Kai and Opal exact same thing.
I really am stoked about these new airbender costumes.
They're gonna stand out really nicely against the metalbending army.
But there are just so many awsome things to talk about.
About just where the Air Nation is right now and it's state of developement.
They're basically like super cops, now being dispached all over the Earth Kingdom by Tenzin.
And you can tell they are pros too. Like they have been doing this for a long time. They're really good.
Even though they've did loose those supplies.
I think that was just to show that they were fighting a battle that they couldn't win.
Like you were supposed to feel like the mayor had no other choice but to sign Kuvira's deal.
Number 6: Tenzin's family all have grown up.
I love seeing Rohan with hair, like we haven't seen him in a long time.
And then there is Milo, who looks like he's about the same age as Kai was during Book 3.
Milo the boy becoming Milo the man was probably the best animation sequence in the episode.
At least next to Kuvira's fight.
We also get a really good look at Jinora with her hair again too.
I know some people really didn't like her being bald.
I didn't have too many issues with it. But she did look exactly like Aang.
But I think that was the point. I think she was supposed to look like Aang.
Or she was supposed to remind us of Aang.
Number 5: Mako is getting sent to Ba Sing Se on permanent duty.
Just one more nail in the coffin of Team Korra.
This is gonna put Mako and Bolin in direct opposition to each other.
Brother against brother.
It's just like Opal's brother is on the opposite side from her.
Like families are going to be in conflict this season.
It's a lot like the United States civil war.
You know. Politics dividing families, dividing the country.
Like is said earlier though, I don't think Team Korra is gonna beat each other throats for too long.
I do think they're gonna have a happy ending.
But, things are gonna get worse before they'll get better.
Number 4: Meet Team Kuvira.
Think about Team Kuvira as being an analog of Team Korra.
Or even Team Zaheer for that matter.
But it's Bolin, Varrick, Zhu Li and one of Opal's brothers.
Not Skrillex, I think his name is Bataar.
The perspective shifts a couple of times. But we're mostly seeing her inner circle from Bolin's perspective.
I am already starting to get a little bit nervous about what's gonna happen to Team Korra though.
The train itself looked amazing, like the high-speed rail.
I got the sense that visually the train was also supposed to represent the unstoppable nature of Kuvira this season.
Like even rocks on the tracks weren't enough to stop her.
She is just metalbending the shit out of everything in her path.
Speking of which. Number 3: Kuvira versus the bandits.
Probably one of the coolest uses of metalbending that I have ever seen.
It reminded me of Book 1 when we saw Korra using more sophisticated bending techniques,
than we have seen on Last Airbender.
And like the metalbending police force, going all Spider-man with their cables.
It just becomes pretty clear that Kuvira is doing everything she can to bring the Earth Kingdom to heel.
Those bandits were so quick to accept her offer of joining the army.
It's sounds like just everyone in general in the Earth Kingdom want some relief.
Like they want some directions, someone to lead them.
And they really don't care who helps them out.
The result is that Kuvira is just constantly adding to her forces.
Whether it be the bandints or the states themselves and all the supplies.
It wasn't really clear when she had that conversation with the mayor, but
the contract said that they had to give her supplies and manpower.
Like that what she was taking from them.
Number 2: Kuvira's unification plan revealed.
So she making all the states swear allegiance in exchange for protection.
It's technically not blackmail.
Unless she sends bandits back to the city.
And that doesn't seem like her flavour of evil.
It feels like something Varrick would have done.
Like whenever he had people hijack Asami's shipments back in Book 2, so she'd go bankrupt.
Remember he also framed Mako for that.
Based on that lego map that Kuvira was putting together...
And yes, it did look like she was playing with legos.
She is almost done with her mission.
Like she's almost completely unified the Earth Kingdom.
The tease being that if she completes the job...
She'll have all the combined resources of the Earth Kingdom at her disposal,
including their manpower.
Most notably their manpower.
So the potential is that she'll decide that she is a better candidate to lead the Earth Kingdom than Wu is.
And you get your conflict.
Like she can raise up an army to fight off any invading force, trying to install Wu on the throne.
Which in this case might end up being the Republic City forces.
Who just happened to be commanded by Zuko's grandson.
We'll have to see how that plays out.
They didn't come right out and say: Kuvira is not gonna give up
controll over the Earth Kingdom when she is done.
But she is the villain. So it's gonna happen pretty soon.
And my number 1 moment - of course: Korra is an underground MMA bender.
Kuvira's been getting sharper - literally.
And Korra looks like she is barely treading water.
Not good.
I totally love the WTF reveal though, of what she's been doing the last six months.
Just basically getting the crap beat out of her.
In the trailer we a saw a big spirit world montage.
If anyone saw Superman 2, like the really old Superman movie with Christopher Reeve.
He basically gave up his powers to become human,
but found out that the world still needed him to be Superman.
So he literally had to hitchhike all the way back to the fortress of solitude
to get his powers back.
Just like we see Korra here marching through the snow back to the spirit portal.
So, yes she is definitely gonna get her mojo back at some point,
but she gonna have to have a call to action.
Something has to change to slap her in the face and wake her up because
right now it looks like she is completely lost.
Let me know what your favorite moment was.
There is a whole lot to pick from.
And let me know, what do you think is gonna be the big call to action,
that's gonna make Korra go back to the spirit portal.
Overall I gave the episode a solid A.
I totally love the way, they got through all that exposition.
And reintroduced us to the characters and the state of the world.
It's like they are just setting up a giant pai sho board.
And now we get to watch the game unfold.
Infact, if you actually rewatch the episode of Book 3
when Asami and Bolin play pai sho.
She has this really good speech about what it takes to win a game.
I bet there is a really good lesson in there for what's gonna happen in Book 4.
So here's a clarification from some of those scenes in the trailer that everyone was confused about.
Cause we actually got most of it answered.
So first off, here is Korra in her MMA outfit in the swamps.
Looking like she gonna get her butt kicked.
Especially when she gets captured in liquid metal.
Here we see Bolin jumping to escape from one of the giant mechs.
You can kinda see him jump down. It's a little fuzzy.
Maybe he turns against Kuvira soon.
Clearly someone else from the army is after him.
This person on the train that Asami is fighting with the short hair, that's Opal's brother.
I konw everyone wondered if it was Bolin or Mako.
Thankfully it is not.
This here though with Korra is Mako at this White Lotus Temple.
No idea where it is located though.
This Toph scene also kinda looks like it came after that big swamp fight scene.
Just because she looks like she got the crap beat out of her.
So yes. I mean Team Avatar is gonna be pushed apart by all these political forces.
But they will come back together eventually.
I'm hoping it's like maybe the third or fourth episode when we see that.
But who knows.
So really good news, for any fans of the comic book.
Bryan Konietzko basically said that he is gonna double down on the comic book.
After Korra Book 4 is out.
Like he is hoping to work more on the comic book.
So I know a lot of people were wondering what's gonna happen with the comics.
They will continue.
If you are wondering where to buy them. You can just get them on Comixology online.
If your local comic book shop doesn't have them.
I will be posting a Q&A for this tomorrow. So be sure to leave all your questions.
There is a whole lot of stuff to talk about.
Right now click here to get to that video. I'll add the annotation as soon as I post it.
And you can click here for my top 10 avatar villains.
Thank you so much for watching.
So let's all high five.
Do not forget: Star Wars Rebels tonight.
Be sure to watch it.